well we all go a little mad sometimes
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue doctor who reviews Marchon and
we have arrived at asylum of the Daleks
I really like this episode I feel like I
need to put that up front and not even
dance around it or be particularly coy
because there are various episodes that
I see cited maybe not all the time but
more often than it could just be a fluke
as like people's least favorite episodes
were like oh well at least this thing
that happened wasn't that one and
usually I like okay I get it
maybe I don't agree but I get it when
people really take issue with closing
time I'll defend aspects of it but I get
it people take issues with in the forest
of the night I don't think it's as bad
as people say it is or at least my
memory of it isn't we'll see when I get
to the rewatch but you know I get it
kill the moon I don't think it really
falls apart until the very end but I get
it asylum of the Daleks when I see this
one pop up with people just be like ah
that was so bad like I'm sorry I don't
get it I think this is terrific I think
this is a great way to kick off after a
bit of a you know stall we had the end
of series 6
we had the Christmas special now we got
to pick things up again I think it just
it works and it's fun and I love the
energy and for all the issues I will
have with Clara
later on I do really like Auslan so yeah
gonna have to defend a lot of aspects of
this aren't I well let's start with one
of the big ones that actually kind of
comes up right at the front end that
I've seen a lot of people cite as a
problem and particularly in regards to
like an example of how Moffett doesn't
get the emotional side of characters
always and that is Amy and Rory's
relationship the fact that at the start
of this episode they are getting
divorced
and how there is this focus from the
doctor about trying to repair their
marriage and sort of the way that that
goes down I've seen a number of
objections to this I've seen people say
they just don't buy it that they split
in the first place I've seen them then
then as a result of that object to it
getting as much focus as it is see for
me this ring is actually really really
really emotionally true because and I'm
not gonna say that this automatically
happens every time but like the simple
fact is that statistically most couples
who lose a child don't stay together and
you know you can make your arguments
about well river didn't die or anything
and they know she's okay and they know
her as well yet but they never got to
raise her they never got the experience
of parenting a child so for all intents
and purposes whether River died or not
and she didn't but even though rivers
still alive
they lost their shot at being parents in
anything vaguely approaching a
traditional way so the emotional impact
on them as a couple is basically the
same and I think it rings really true
because the splits that happen over
things like that the breakdown of
relationships of communications between
couples yeah that tracks to me and if
they're going to go down that path which
again I think makes a certain degree
emotional sense I mean for everything
that they have gone through in the tail
end of series 6 yeah that's gonna fray
them over time and maybe the issue some
people have is the fact that the split
seemed to have happened later you know
because obviously we knew that two years
after the doctor left he stopped in for
Christmas so they were still together
then yeah but we only get a tiny glimpse
and they very easily could have been in
not a great situation at the point that
that happened not every split happens
one night because of a big blowup fight
these things can happen over time and I
think if they were going to go that
route which is one that again I feel is
valid I think it makes sense to jump in
at the point that we're at because
otherwise well we'd have to spend at
least half a series watching this
relationship fall apart and at least
speaking personally I don't want to
watch that I just don't and I also don't
need to because I buy it so that's Amy
and Rory and again like and I and I buy
the rationale I buy the fight that they
have where Rory takes it as a given that
he loves Amy more than she loves him and
she she sees breaking up with him as
letting him go because she knows how
much he wants kids and she she can't
have more not since melody and they
obviously again effectively lost her so
I again I buy it now a big part of that
is probably sold by the performances of
Karen Gillan and Arthur Darvill because
they're just great these parts and they
have great chemistry and they really
know how to make these moments work
because with actors who didn't know how
to sell it yeah it would fall apart but
for me that works the whole idea of the
Daleks coming in and basically hijacking
the doctor to send him on a mission that
they're scared to do is it a little
ridiculous
this yeah but it's a fun kind of
ridiculous and that's the thing about
this episode my main thing that I love
about this episode this episode is fun
and it manages to be fun without being
overly goofy at least I don't feel it is
because sometimes when the doctor who
goes for fun it gets a little bit more
in the area of camp this is just a
rollicking adventure the doctors got
great lines I love he's in the
parliament of the Daleks and I was just
going save the Daleks he's just there
well this is new like that's the perfect
reaction as far as I'm concerned I
absolutely love that and the the whole
thing that goes on in terms of them
having to infiltrate and he gets the the
banter going with Oswin and Oswin starts
flirting with Rory and then says well
now you know my first crush was named
Rory actually she was named Nina then
she says I was going through her phase
which I really wish she didn't say the
whole idea of bisexuality or or anything
like that being a phase something people
get over you know some people do have an
experimental thing but it's a phase is
such a dead horse I really didn't love
seeing that but other than that the
general vibe of those interactions I
enjoy I love that she immediately starts
ribbing Matt Smith for his chin and goes
after Rory for the nose so I just have
so much fun with this I have somewhat
mixed feelings about some of the things
that are done when I put it in the mix
in the context of the show as a whole I
think self-contained as a story
I just mean this is a great time however
when we get to things like the Dalek
puppets it's not a bad idea but it is
the kind of thing where I feel like it
it's kind of cheat and it's one of those
things that becomes a case of oh god
that you know the Daleks are either
gonna run this into the ground
or we're gonna keep wondering why didn't
they do that
and I don't think they handled them in
the future
overly badly but it is that kind of
element getting introduced into things
it's kind of interesting but it is I'm
not sure it was worth it overall and
then there's also the whole idea of
ending it on the on the notion that the
doctor has been wiped from the memory of
the Daleks which I would have been down
for if they'd stuck to it like that had
no meaning and that and that's probably
part of my frustration with that is that
you know the end of series 6 we had this
whole setup of I've been too noisy I
need to get back to the shadows and this
would have fed directly into that now
the Daleks don't even remember who he is
and that just doesn't really just
doesn't really pan out to be the case I
really am a noir with a show that it
kind of abandoned that edict pretty much
immediately now the the realization
about Oswin being a Dalek who basically
has mentally not yet accepted that that
is what she is that for me if that
worked that worked well enough I don't
know if it works necessarily as a twist
I think I called it not super early
probably about two or three minutes
before the reveal happened which I don't
think is too far ahead of it so I think
it's pretty well handled and it it trams
going back and watching it another time
like know that tracks and I like that
they hints get dropped into the banter
and not a ton of highlights brought to
them you know she's souffles the diary
like souffles guess the Daleks where did
he get the milk and then he gets
interrupted you know like this is a
silly conversation but you know there's
your clues there's your hints I think
that's actually well sprinkled
throughout the thing I don't know if
part of the reason people don't like
this episode or at least
in my interactions people seem to not
like this episode is possibly because as
a season opener they wanted something a
bit more serious I don't know like I
said it I just find this episode of fun
I find it fun and enjoyable I've seen it
accused of like fan pandering because
it's got all the different kinds of
Daleks and I'm not gonna say that
necessarily isn't the case but I know
that had like no way impact on me I
don't think I even spotted the special
weapons Dalek until like the second time
I watched it so yeah I just enjoy this I
find it to be a nice rollicking
adventure that introduces a in my
opinion superior version of Clara a
version who we understand who she is the
kind of person that she is between the
music that she listens to and what she
does in her spare time and the banter
that she has with multiple characters I
get such an immediate sense of Oswin
it's something I won't get from Clara
later on but we'll burn that bridge when
we get to it but she's great in this so
like for me the issue was never the
actress it was never her Jenna Coleman
it was the character of Clara but again
yeah we'll get there sooner than I'd
like but I just I find it I find it fun
and entertaining and they managed to
weave what was for me an emotionally
true story when it comes to Amy and Rory
I bought it it worked I enjoyed this
episode there you go Cylon of the Daleks
Yuri watched it lately what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down on the comments let's
talk about it there's a bunch of stuff
to do you can support me on patreon even
a dollar a month is the help and it gets
you early access to select videos such
as the overdue Doctor Who reviews and of
course there's also the usual
like subscribe share this video around
follow me on Twitter bla bla bla bla bla
bla Elsa don't have to cuz you know what
at the end of the day Wow
you're the council and I'm just rounding
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]